[Music]
my name is Ronnie Luce and I'm gonna
talk to you about a work it's joint with
a very big team that we worked on to
release this toolkit this past summer
with researchers and software developers
from IBM from Yorktown which is one of
our research facilities about 40 minutes
north of here India and Argentina so we
titled this one explanation does not fit
all about explain ability for AI because
there's many different people with many
different reasons for wanting explain
ability so when we talked about a
taxonomy we're talking about the need to
define different tools for explain
ability everyone has a different goal in
mind that I'm going to get into that so
the agenda for the talk first I'm going
to talk about why we need AI to be
explainable then I'll spend some times
talking more directly about the
algorithms that were developed at IBM
and then I'm gonna show a little bit of
a tutorial on this toolkit that we
released which is called AIX 360 okay so
everyone knows that AI is becoming very
abundant used everywhere many different
disciplines used by banks to determine
credit limits that's been in the news
very recently employment admission it's
used to predict things about retention
who to target for applicants even to
college for sentencing it's used in
parole guidelines all over these are
very real world applications very real
life a lot at stake so as AI has been
used much more in all these different
disciplines computational resources have
increased a lot over the past 20 years a
lot new things can be done and
applications we didn't think about back
then now we can achieve so-called 99%
accuracy and probably better on many
applications question is if you're
actually using a
you're developing new tools in AI how do
you get people to actually use these AI
tools you say has 99% accuracy that's
really great but there's still in
society I think a lack of trust in using
AI you really need there's in these real
world applications if you don't have
that trust even though it's 99% accurate
you're not gonna use it so this is a non
exhaustive list of what you might think
of what do we want AI to give us what
questions can we ask is it fair why did
it make this decision is it accountable
questions we asked a of AI questions we
asked of many other things and I'll say
that a lot of these messages these talk
just gave was very good so I'm going to
agree and say that a lot of this is the
same message of what she was saying that
in AI we need a lot of responsibility
everything that I'm talking about is not
new it's been in the news for a long
time lots of different companies are
using AI tools across many different
things the headline here when a computer
program keeps you in jail about hey I
was used in determining parole for
people and if you make mistakes the
consequences affect people's lives so
the quest for explainable AI is a very
real and a very necessary thing to look
at when we ask for explainable AI
question is what are we asking for we're
not the first person to ask this
question we're not the first person to
say what should we ask so for example
the GDP our regulations that came out
they defined saying people are what they
should be given is the right to be
provided with meaningful information
about decisions that are given to them
by these AI tools what is meaningful
mean that's something we've tried to
define we're on our way but it's
certainly not a finished product so how
can we define what is meaningful we
asked what can explainable
give us and what do we want to get out
of it so I'm going to go through a short
list of a few of the things we're going
to ask of it and a few of the tools that
we want to understand from AI in order
to get people to trust it so I'll start
with simplification we have a
complicated network here for example and
the task is deciding whether or not a
piece of code is malware so in some
applications someone came up with this
very complicated neural network that a
human looks at it you can't understand
what's going on a couple engineers
analyze what the output is and they find
out well what it's really doing is
predicting that does this code have
comments or not because evidently people
that write malware don't care much to
document their code do we need a
complicated neural network to classify
using such intuition so if we could
explain what the model is doing we can
come up with simpler models the next
thing is uh debugging so here we have a
task of a self-driving car and it slows
down at the red light but it doesn't
stop so we want to be able to explain
why is it not stopping why do we want to
explain it we don't want to get rid of
self-driving cars we want to be able to
get this moving along we want to be able
to debug the program and figure out
what's going on so we can get systems
that work the existence of confounders
so one thing we want to be able to get
from explanation is to identify spurious
correlations so if you took a data set
medical data set you could possibly come
up with the intuition that pneumonia
causes is indicative of someone not
having diabetes this comes up in a data
set when people have pneumonia and you
create your correlations however what's
missing is the fact that people who have
pneumonia generally go to the hospital
when you get a mid to the hospital
everyone gets checked for diabetes and
most people don't have diabetes so
unless you know that people were in the
hospital you're going to think that just
because you had pneumonia you don't have
diabetes which is very very much not
true so we need to explain why this
decision is being made
the key thing that we just heard about
in the last talk also fairness is the
decision system making a fair decision
what does fair mean this is a whole
topic for discussion of course but AI
does need to be fair I think we can all
agree on that robustness and
generalizability is a system making
decisions based on the features it
should be so here you have a dog in the
winter maybe it's a wolf and the
question is is it being predicted the
correct class species of wolf because of
what it looks like or because of its
environment what's the correct features
that it should be looking at and we want
to be able to understand that from the
model as well ok so this is the story so
far
AI is everywhere we need to explain it
and there's many reasons on why we want
to explain it so now let's talk about
different types of ways you can explain
models in AI so the toolkit that I'm
gonna give a tutorial on is called
AI x360 that we developed at IBM it was
released in July it's open source you
can get it on github what I have to top
your a bunch of different dimensions
that we can classify different methods
for explain ability under there's a
bunch of different toolkits out there
already so we're just putting this to
differentiate ourselves a little bit
for example the Microsoft tool that
Audie discussed so it has some of the
tools are the same but the main thing in
our toolbox from the beginning was that
we only included homegrown IBM tools
into it and the hope to show some
success is that people are going to also
put their own tools into our tool kit so
the purpose of this is also apart
research in part for everyone to
contribute and work together
so the these dimensions of explained
ability so the idea here is to create a
text anomie so the idea no explaining
not one fits all no there's no
explanation for one explanation for
every problem because there's many
different dimensions to look at so the
first one we're going to consider in
this taxonomy is directly interprete
below verse post hoc interpretations
what this dimension means you have a
class of models that's already
interpretable decision rules trees
things that you can as a human look at
and understand why is the model giving
its prediction so we have those types of
models versus post hoc interpretation
where you have a very complicated model
like the neural network and the way
we're gonna explain it is using some
type of surrogate or approximation
something simpler for example one of
these directly interpretive models that
approximates a complicated network and
we're gonna get intuition out of that at
the next dimension we're gonna look at
global versus local explain ability
global is where you are a person and you
care about generally what's going on in
the model how it goes how it predicts
across an entire distribution of data
versus local where you want to explain
why is this model predicting this
classification on a particular instance
and then the last dimension is static
where you're simply presenting the
interpretation to the user versus a more
visual interpretation where the user can
interact with the interpretation that we
call interactive so here's the taxonomy
so at the top we have static versus
interactive a x360 doesn't yet have any
visual analytics so we're only sticking
with static if we go to the next branch
data versus model so we have explain
ability for data so if you have
complicated data that you don't
understand and we want to be able to
interpret the features we have some
tools for that for example dip VI e
which is in the tool box if we look on
the other side I'll focus on that
understanding models for the next branch
we have local versus global tools on the
global side we have again direct versus
post hoc one of the direct tools be our
CG
that was implemented at IBM is called
boolean rules via column generation it's
basically a rule list of and then the PO
stock is surrogates that you can use to
explain a complicated model afterwards
so for example we have a tall discus
called prof way if we look on the other
side local tools we can look at PO stock
versus self explaining and post talk
what we have is a tool for looking at
either samples of features samples
meaning we're going to give an
explanation for a data point based on
looking at other data points in the data
setting even which data points a group
of data points is similar to this data
point they give us some intuition versus
features where we're trying to look
answer questions such as how can I
change this data point in order to
achieve a different classification and
what intuition do I get from that so now
I'll dive a little bit more into these
tools so we'll start with the directly
global interpreter will model so these
are the ones that we look at that as a
human you can look at and understand
what's going on a decision tree or a
rule list you look at the top and based
on whatever the prediction is for your
data point you can trace down and figure
out exactly what's going on and of
course we can debate if this is really
interprete below to a human because if
this tree goes down a thousand lines
then maybe we have to use some other
surrogate and try and approximate it
with a shorter decision tree even which
we've done so the tool in a x360 one of
them is called be our CG the boolean
decision rules via column generation and
essentially this is a rule list that is
made of what are called DNF formulas
disjunctive normal form formulas or is a
van so what that means you get a rule
that says classify this as a one if a
and B and C happen or if x and y and z
happens or if D and E and F happens and
so forth and so you just get a big rule
list that you can look at and understand
what's going on a variant of this
technique actually won last year in the
oops 2018 fecal challenge which was a
credit challenge explaining why people
were approved or denied on loans then
another tool we have for the postdoc
interpretation sorry for the postdoc
interpretation we're explaining a
complicated Network instead and what we
want to do is explain how it's surrogate
so we have our deep neural network and
on the right we can either use decision
trees or a simple curve fitting or even
a simpler neural network that maybe we
can't understand you can use in samples
of these simple models to try and
explain the deep neural network and a
tool in AIX 360 this is dealing with the
one called prof way the idea here was to
explain a complex neural network by
transferring information to a simple
model so specifically say that you're
someone that's really fixed on using
your decision tree you're in
manufacturing and you predict things
using your simple decision tree you
don't want to use a complicated neural
network even though it'll give you
better accuracy what we do here by using
the complicated neural what network is
transfer information to improve the
performance of your decision tree so
even though what you were using was one
decision tree we give you a new one
that just performs better so you don't
still have to use the complicated
network that you don't understand and
the goal there is also on some
applications to try and improve the
performance of the simple model somewhat
near what the complex model can do and
caveat to just mentioned stuff like this
has already been done one topic called
knowledge distillation where from neural
networks they transfer information by
fitting a simple model to the
predictions of the neural network this
is what knowledge distillation
essentially does and what we're doing is
creating transfer information transfer
by taking a neural network we extract
information from different layers of the
network that's what these logistic
probes are called so say you cut off
the network after two layers and you
added a classifier after two layers you
get your prediction we can extract
information that way on how well the
neural network is performing with only
its first two layers its first three
layers and so forth and then we can
extract that information to wait the
data points on a simple model and
improve it that way so after post-hoc
global interpretations now we're gonna
look at post off local interpretations
one of the more classic things that has
been done there called saliency maps
which are very nice specifically for
image data
it's the idea with Stanley and C maps is
essentially you classify amid the goal
here again let me just go back our goal
is to explain why classifier is
outputting something whether or not that
output is correct or not that's not what
I care about I want to explain why it's
saying what it's saying if it gives a
bad classification I want to give an
explanation why it's giving that bad
classification so I can know it's not a
good classifier maybe I can fix it so
here for the Saleen C maps what it does
is take the gradient of the classifier
and evaluate that at the point
essentially what this says is what is
the relevant parts of the image towards
the output of the classifier that's what
you get from taking the gradient in this
manner so the Saleen C maps are on the
bottom row and it highlights like for
the first image on the Left where the
boat is essentially this is classifying
what the image is so it's highlighting
the most important part of the image the
problem I would say with Stanley and C
maps is that afterwards a human needs to
really look at that stay on C map and
explain understand what's going on you
can't just read that and get your
explanation so one of the things that we
looked at was giving alternative types
of explanations at a local level and
what we went with were contrastive
explanations so in contrast of
explanations we want to take a data
point in its classifier so here the
person in the upper left is classified
as a young male and
smiling and we want to explain why this
classifier says he's young male and
smiling and the way we're gonna do that
is by saying what attributes minimal set
of attributes that I say would we add to
this person such that the classifier
would classify him as something
different and so what that's called is
the pertinent negative explanation so
for this instance in the back column on
the bottom if we add brown hair makeup
in bangs to this young man he would be
classified as an old female who's still
smiling and one of the cool things is
that we can also not just give out this
application we can modify the data point
and show what that data point would look
like with these extra attributes so this
is called the pertinent negative that's
one part of contrastive explanations one
part I'm not so sure here is also called
the pertinent positive which would look
at this young male smiling and say
what's the minimal sufficient attributes
he needs to maintain so that he's still
going to be predicted at young male
smiling so basically it's saying what
are the attributes that the classifier
is focused on that maintains him to be
classified as such okay so those are all
the tools that I wanted to discuss so
far and before we get into the tutorial
I just want to reiterate what the
message is here that one explanation
does not fit all you have different
stakeholders everyone cares about
something different and there's the
examples there's not enough or sorry
there's too many so for example if
you're a doctor and you're using AI to
predict on an image that someone has
cancer how do you get someone to trust
that how do you get the doctor to trust
to use this tool so he's asking why did
you recommend me this treatment that's
his question from AI because he's not
gonna go and use such a tool unless he
really understands and trusts that tool
if you're applying for your loan and you
are denied you want to understand why
did it deny me why because you'd like to
make changes to your applications so
that a year from now you can qualify for
your mortgage
your car loan regulatory bodies the
government what's their interest proving
that the system doesn't destroy many why
because hopefully they care about
society and want to do the right thing
then you have the AI systems builders
stakeholders the developers the
engineers creating these tools what do
they want they want to know is the
system performing well is it giving good
accuracy is it doing all the other stuff
and giving explain ability as well
because their job is to give us good
tools so everyone has a different thing
they need from explain ability and so we
wanted to create this taxonomy to appeal
to a large variety of stakeholders okay
so now I'm gonna give it a little
tutorial about ax 316 gonna focus on two
examples one of them is that contrastive
execs planation example that I went into
and another will be the Pico example
using several of the tools from the X
360 like the ones that won that
competition last year ok so you can
download a X 360 on github it's an open
source library one of the nice things
that we did and worked hard on was
creating a lot of tutorials an example
notebook so people can dive right in
understand how to use it and hopefully
plug in their own tools so we're going
to go to the examples folder but
basically there's a few different things
in the ax 360 folder is all the
algorithms there's documentation so if
we go in the example folders these are
different types of algorithms that we
have contrastive has two different types
of methods for contrast of explanations
the BAA was something i mentioned if you
need to explain the features in a data
set so one nice application of that for
example is if you're dealing with the
data set that doesn't have attributes
you understand DP is a tool to extract
and transform to variables that you can
get interpretations for so then you're
going to plug more interpretable
features into your model
we have different metrics Prof way was
one of the global post hoc examples that
I showed you
proto dash is a tool for finding
prototypes of a data set of a sample
point RB M has the boolean rule lists
and then Limon shape were as you see 15
days ago was recently implemented but
originally we started with our own IBM
homegrown tools and Limon shape or
things that were not homegrown to us but
we want to build this using everyone's
AI tools as well we want to create a
tool for everybody ok so let's look at
the first tutorial that I want to go
over explaining neural network decisions
on data that have high-level attributes
so this is an example using contrastive
explanations and specifically for data
that has predefined high-level
attributes so that data set that I
showed you before with the images this
is called celibate it's a facial images
and it has predefined high-level
attributes meaning it has attributes
saying whether you're smiling whether
you're old whether what color your
eyebrows are what color your hair is are
you wearing makeup bangs features about
your nose your ears glasses and for this
tool we need to have such high level
attributes so actually in the paper we
wrote about this we have other examples
where you don't have high level
attributes but you can use that dip baé
tool to extract interpretable features
and then we can get contrast of
explanations using those so this is a
tool again for getting pertinent
positives and pertinent negatives ok so
what does the tool look like any other
tool we have a few open source libraries
here we need tensorflow
and then we have the AIX 360 tools
specifically we have wrappers for the
different explainers so you have a model
that you have to give a wrapper to and
then we have explainer objects so you
can explain different types of models
and also for all these tutorials we
explain the public data sets that we're
using how you
and download them or even here we have
tools that'll download it for you so we
start a tensorflow session we load the
model to be explained so again this is
about explaining a model not about
actually getting having an
interpretative model I have a model that
is definitely not interpreted well it's
a really large neural network and my
goal is to explain it somehow and here
we define explanations using contrastive
explanations so we wrapped this model
into a the framework we download a
sample image here we're gonna plat him
and what does he look like he's not
young he's not smiling and it's he he's
a male so that's what the classifier
actually says no that's what this model
predicts and that's what he clearly
looks like to us but imagine that the
classifier predicted he was a female and
he's not smiling in he's young we still
want an explanation why is the model
telling us that and you would use this
tool to give us answers to that question
as well okay at the top here we create
an explainer object and as with all
these explanation tools you have
different parameters you can get an idea
of what these parameters mean if you
read the papers that are cited in the
tutorials we run the algorithm so here
it's loading models for black hair of
her blouse hair for brown hair so this
is a tool where I said we need
high-level attributes we also need pre
trains classifiers on these attributes
something to tell does this image
exhibit someone with black hair with
blonde hair or wearing lipstick and so
forth we're going to use those
classifiers to generate contrast of
explanations
it runs the algorithm eventually it
finishes and it's going to give us an
output it output the pertinent negative
explanation is a male smiling and not
young so before he was not smiling now
it says he's smiling
and the explanation why is he smiling
because it added high cheekbones to the
picture so let's go back to the other
picture you see I was Malthus now it
made him a little more smiling and why
it says it added high cheekbones this is
what the algorithm learned by looking at
all the attributes and the nice thing is
it changed the actual picture so what's
the actual contrast of explanation is
that we would have predicted this person
to be a male not smiling not young
unless we would add these high
cheekbones in which he would now be a
male smiling and not young that's our
explanation and this is done in plenty
of places like for predicting whether
someone has the flu versus they have
something else a doctor will look at ok
you have a fever but you're not coughing
so that's if you had if you were
coughing you'd be perhaps you have
pneumonia and not the flu this is what
we mean by contrast of explanations and
it's used all over the place and there
are as articles that say this is the
more intuitive way that humans actually
process explanations so this is the
pertinent negative there's also a
pertinent positive in the tutorial but I
am going to skip that for now so now we
will look at the credit approval
tutorial so this is what the FICO data
and so there's three different
stakeholders in this tutorial the data
scientist who's providing the model and
he wants to know why it's giving at the
outputs it's given so that he can tweak
it and make it a better model he wants
to trust it for himself the loan officer
who is using the model and he wants to
know he just denied an applicant why is
he denying this applicant can he see a
group of applicants that's similar to
this applicant that makes him understand
why he's denying that applicant then you
have the bank customer who wants to know
how can they change their applications
so they're approved next time usually
someone that's approved doesn't want to
know how they get tonight
so this bank customer is going to use
contrastive explanations so we've
already seen that
I'm gonna stick with the data scientist
and the loan officer for now okay so the
data scientist here there's different
tools you can use in the ax 360 boolean
rules and a logistic rule regression
model I'm gonna stick with the boolean
rules right now so we load the data and
we print out here's what the data looks
like so you have anonymized customers
and columns and a sample of the
different types of variables the
features of our applicants external risk
estimate is actually the lower you are
the worst you are as an applicant the
more risk you are for example for
boolean rule lists again we're creating
if you remember before I said we're
creating or zoo vans so a rule that says
x and y and z so looking at those
numbers before we can't just make rules
so you have to binarize the data so what
that means is for each attribute we
create these new features so a feature
it says whether or not for your risk
estimate your value is less than or
equal to 59 another feature it says
whether or not you're less than or equal
to 63 and so forth and also for the
greater than on the other side is your
risk guys to make greater than 59
greater than 63 so we create binarize
and create all these features and all
the different inputs then we run the
boolean rule column generation and we
get our output at the bottom which says
predict y equals 0 if any of the
following rules are satisfied otherwise
y equals 1 y equals 0 says that you are
a risky person a bad applicant and
you're likely not to repay your loan and
what it says here two different rules if
your external risk estimate is less
turning to 75 and your number of
satisfactory trades as last-minute 17
and another rule very similar we should
reject you this classifier had something
like 67 or 68 percent on the data set
with just two rules and so even with
very complicated data we can learn very
simple rules explainable rules that you
can look at and understand
the output of your model we have the
loan officer now so the loan officer is
the one who is telling you whether you
were approved or denied and he doesn't
like denying people so he wants to know
and he denies someone what is it that
caused him to die he wants to know he
made the right choice so again we import
the models that we need we use their 360
tools that we need here it's the proto -
tool and the HELOC data set we load our
data a few things that I'm skipping
processing normalizing the data for this
tool defining and training a neural
network classifier so we want to explain
the classifier this classifier is just
going to stand for something that this
is the loan approval model we're
assuming and we want to explain why is
this neural net classifier approving and
denying people so we obtain a similar
similar samples as explanations for a
HELOC applicant predicted as good here
so the chosen sample was 8
this person was predicted good at the
bottom and it has what his sample
probabilities would be we run the proto
- explainer which is a wrapper for a
x360 around the tools developed in a
paper cited in the tutorial the optimal
solution has been found after a while
and then we display similar users so we
look at these users now what does this
loan officer do you can look at these
five users that are prototypes now let
me be clear these are five previous
applicants that went through this model
and we're either approved or accepted
here they were approved and that's in
contrast to the explanation tool before
we we generated a new sample point for
the contrast of explanation so here we
look at five people that were previously
approved and he's trying to figure out
why was my current applicant who's
similar to this group what does he have
in common and most of the prototypes
have no debt so he falls into a class of
people that have no debt and that's why
he was mostly
khaleesi not risky and approved this is
how we can the loan officer can use this
tool okay so that's it for the tutorial
that I want to give I'm gonna say just a
few more words on all these toolkits so
what I've talked about today is a I
explained ability 360 we released some
other tools related to trust as well
adversarial robustness 360 last year AI
fairness 360 and one of the next things
that we want to work on is causal
inference 360 and the goal it's the
support a community of users and
contributors not just IBM we want
everyone to be able to download and
contribute to these tools so we hope
that we've made it easy for people to
plug in their tools themselves and
lastly this again I said in the
beginning this was developed by many
people not just myself more than 15
researchers engineers across at least
three continents so thank you hi so I
had a one question was there's one
popular technique I'm aware of called
lime or key lime I think it was also in
your game repo where would you put that
in your tics honoré like which
definition would you point my name is a
local I would call that a local
interpretability tool so lime is looking
at specific instances so you have a
complicated model and it's effectively
trying to get local interpreted using
linear approximations locally to explain
a specific data point so if you look to
prop the only problem lime is used by a
lot of people the only problem is that
when you look at data points that are
somewhat close you might get different
explanations so there's some work to say
how can we use something like lime but
also it's a little weird to give
explanation different explanations or
data points that are very similar so
some type of lime like tool that'll give
explanations near each other but I would
say it's a local tool sorry yeah what
are your thoughts on using stuff like
dimension reduction
to give you like a sense of which were
the key properties that were looked at
in why yeah um I would say that that is
widely used and necessary so for example
the dip VA you it's not how many if you
have a large dimensional data set that
you don't understand and we want to get
new features so they're those thing is
it's called disentangle direct
presentations so disentangled meaning
you want representations that the
features are somewhat orthogonal to each
other so you can get some type of
interpretation there's not much overlap
between them and so with high
dimensional data
there's definitely need for variable
reduction if you want especially if
you're trying to explain the data itself
[Music]